What did Jesus say about Israel or
Jerusalem here? Black and white,
Revelation 11:8.
And their dead bodies will lie in the
street of the great city, which
spiritually is called Sodom and go
Egypt, where also their Lord was
crucified. Well, where was Jesus killed?
Jerusalem.
What did Jesus tell John to call
Jerusalem?
Jerusalem is the new Sodom and Egypt,
and this was 2,000 years ago.
This was 2,000 years ago.
When our Lord said this, this was 2,000
years ago.
How much more is it Sodom and Egypt
today?
Right?
See, your Bible already disclosed this,
revealed this.
See that?
Our Lord wasn't crucified in Rome.
He wasn't crucified in America, in
Hawaii.
It was Jerusalem. And he says, "It is
spiritual Sodom and Egypt."
Spiritual Sodom and Egypt.
Yeah, he gave them a chance, but then
they rejected him, and that's why he
goes, "Now the sign is I'm going to
destroy Jerusalem and the temple, and
I'm going to take the kingdom from you."
Yep, exactly.
Flavius Josephus
and the things that Nero was doing,
cross-dressing and
acting like a female and
being mounted, I mean,
anyway, you see that, right? Is that
ironic? What's the number one city
for homosexuality? One more time.
And I got one more clip to play.
in the word of God. They are the enemy
of the gospel.
In June of 2014, during gay pride month,
the United States Embassy flew the
American flag, and underneath the
American flag they hoisted the gay pride
flag.
And for the last few years now Tel Aviv
has been voted the number one gay city
in the world amongst the gay community
themselves. They have voted Tel Aviv as
the number one place in the world, not
San Francisco, not New York,
but Tel Aviv.
So you're telling me
this is God's prophecy being fulfilled.
He brought them into land. He's blessing
them. He's fighting for them. He's
honoring them. In spite of their wicked,
filthy, immorality,
hatred of Christ, persecution of the
gospel.
I thought those were the reasons why God
hated them and rejected them. But you're
saying, "No, in spite of that, they're
still God's people and he's fighting for
them." Really?
And isn't it amazing John already nailed
it? John in Revelation said, "Jerusalem
is spiritual Sodom and Egypt." And that
was 2,000 years ago. Imagine what John
would say about it if he saw it now.
Now, guess who their Messiah is. This is
what's going to shock you, the final
part.
Final part here, 48 minutes and we're
going to talk about Jesus and Talmud.
I'm not done yet with that and then
we'll see. I'll probably do
Psalm 82 tomorrow, God willing.
Tell me, when they describe their
Messiah, who does it sound like?
Now watch this document and I'll give
you the link to the other one,
dispensationalism.
destroying it. Where did the satanic
doctrine of Christian Zionism
originated?
Okay, watch here.
Tell me who their Messiah it sounds
like, okay?
Christ. You have to believe that there
is a Christ and that it's not Jesus.
John 4 tells us that the word Messiah
means Christ. The woman at the well, she
said, "I know that Messiah is cometh,
which is called Christ." So we know that
the definition of the word Christ is
Messiah. So in 1st John 2:22, when it
says, "Who is a liar but he that denied
that Jesus is the Christ?" What it's
saying is, "Who is a liar but he that
denied that Jesus is the Messiah?" So,
you know, what group of people believes
that there is a Messiah but does not
believe that Jesus was that Messiah?
Again, those are the Jews. Let me just
see if I can characterize this right
then. Basically, the the the Jewish
belief on Jesus is I mean Orthodox
synagogue in Arizona cuz he's from
Arizona. So, look. What's the Jewish
belief about Jesus? Listen.
And you obviously doesn't don't believe
he was the Messiah but you just kind of
think he was just kind of just another
in a long string of false Messiahs.
If if
Yes.
>> If he even claimed to be that
>> or he was If the claim was made if if
the claim was made that he's a Messiah,
he's a false Messiah.
Jesus never said,
"I am the Messiah." The Jewish people
would be would have been interested in
the Messiah.
>> Right. They're waiting for Messiah. They
want Messiah.
>> Yeah. So, if he had any of the real
characteristics of a Messiah, they would
have been interested.
>> Mhm. They would have checked and so on
and so forth. But he had 12 disciples.
That's not a lot. I mean, you know,
you're talking about the nation of the
Jews with all the scholars. Right. They
weren't won over to him.
>> believe in him.
>> Not at all. The Christians invented the
idea of a failed Messiah. Even though he
failed, he's still the Messiah. We
reject that. If
if you fail, then you're not the
Messiah.
They're still looking for another
Messiah to come.
And we know that that other Messiah
that's coming is the Antichrist. What
>> What does a Jewish Messiah look like? A
very powerful king that will establish
peace and goodwill on earth. You have to
be able to establish peace. World peace.
World peace. World peace. He says, "When
the real Messiah makes his appearance in
such a dramatic fashion that it can't be
denied, then everybody will acknowledge
that he's the real Messiah." And that
worldwide worldwide. Even the non-Jews
because of cuz they're all looking
forward to the Messiah.
>> So, when the Messiah comes, you're
saying the whole world's going to
believe on him. Yeah. The one the
Messiah comes, world peace, the whole
world will believe on him. Now, watch.
Tell me, as they describe the Messiah,
what comes to your mind?
What
arises in your mind? Listen carefully.
So, last clip I'm going to play from
here.
Okay? Listen carefully. Hmm.
What does that sound like? Their
Messiah, who does he sound like?
Okay, ready?
All right.
the entire world because his purpose
will be to bring the entire world to the
proper observance. All the nations will
stream towards Jerusalem to learn from
him. Okay. It will initiate a period of
world peace. Mhm. World peace.
>> will be a tremendous charismatic figure
with great great knowledge and
communication skills. He'll also be a
great warrior.
Damn.
It's so scary. It's like he's quoting
Revelation 13 and 2 Thessalonians 2
and 1 Thessalonians 5.
He just described his Messiah as the
Antichrist.
You understand, Christians, when you
support Israel
and you send them money,
you are supporting them to prepare for
the coming of the Antichrist.
You are helping them
speed up the coming of the Antichrist
cuz they're waiting for the Antichrist
to come.
And they're trying to do all they can to
build the temple in anticipation of
their Messiah who's the Antichrist.
You're paying for that?
He will be the defender of the Jews, and
he will defeat all their enemies in a
permanent kind of a way. If you listen
to how the Jews describe their Messiah,
they paint a perfect picture of what the
Bible describes as the Antichrist.
He's going to conquer the entire world.
He's going to bring peace through war.
He's going to be believed on by all
religions of the world. He's going to
bring world peace. He's going to unite
us all.
So many Christians are precious and they
don't know what they're doing. They
don't know what they're doing.
Go watch the debate between Andrew
Wilson and Rizwan. Andrew Wilson kept
hammering him saying as a Christian you
cannot support the modern state of
Israel cuz you're supporting their
Antichrist. They reject your Messiah,
your Jesus, and they're waiting for the
Antichrist. Rizwan, send the debate, go
watch it. He kept saying it.
Remember that?
He kept saying it. Let me see if that
was the only clip cuz I want to go into
Jesus on the toilet. Hold on.
Let's see. Was that it?
52:46. Let's Let's play that, okay.
Yeah, let's go here. Listen. You know, I
I I was at a prophecy conference in
Florida.
And a lady came up to me and she was
wearing the the star of David.
And
I asked her why she was wearing that.
She says, "Oh, well,
this is so important that that we show
our support for Israel."
I said, "How do you show your support
for Israel?" Well, she says, "I give
money every month to the Temple Mount
Foundation."
I give money every month month to the
Temple Mount Foundation to help them
rebuild the third temple.
>> [laughter]
>> I give money every month.
Jared?
You guys see that? All right, let's
finish it. A few more seconds.
Well, that's just this Jewish group.
And I said, "Don't you know that 2
Thessalonians chapter 2
says the Antichrist will go into that
temple and declare himself God
and above every other god?"
She says, "Well,
I just think I'm helping to fulfill
Bible prophecy." I said, "You are.
You're helping the Antichrist to come."
I think I'm just helping fulfill
prophecy. Indeed you are. You're
hastening
the coming of the Antichrist. So,
Christians, you're paying for Antichrist
to arise.
Leaving
on a jet plane. I don't know if I'll be
back again. No,
the Mahdi is not the Antichrist, man.
Don't go into that.
And I pack my bags, ready to go. And
what Who would want to do that?
When a man comes Look.
Rabbi Jeremy Gimpel
Look what he says. Tell me who he's
talking about. When a man comes
director of world Mizrahi movement.
Listen.
Guys
you should your hairs on the back of
your
hand should stand up. You should get
shivers on your spine.
Tell me who he's describing. When a man
comes
and he fights the wars of Israel,
defeats the enemies, builds a temple,
peace on Earth. The leader that did that
we will all kneel before the king. Do
you know what I mean? Whoever that is
Whoever that is.
>> So
your vision of that You say it's a
second coming. Okay. We say it's a first
coming.
Okay, you say second coming, we'll say
it's the first coming.
Leaving
on You know what's ironic?
Leonard Nimoy
Turned out he was a Jew, too. Do you
know that sign, that Spock sign that he
does?
You know Leonard Nimoy, when he used to
do this, the Spock sign?
I learned that from the documentary.
They have a clip.
That's the letter sheen.
He's actually pronouncing a rabbinic
blessing on you.
You know that here, let me find that.
Leaving on a jet plane.
I don't know if I'll be back again. Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Let me see if I can find it. Make sure
you watch this entire thing cuz I can't
play everything. I don't want to get
flagged.
Phenomenal. Phenomenal.
And then I'm going to give you the link
to the dispensationalism. Where did this
all start from? About 200 years ago, a
young girl had a vision supposedly from
God.
John Nelson Darby and Scofield bought
into it.
And they became the impetus to poison
evangelicalism.
Where is Leonard Nimoy? Let me find him.
Leaving
on a jet plane. He says, "It's the sheen
sign."
The sheen.
Sheen, maybe.
Let me see if I can find him. Hold on.
We're almost Are you guys not bored,
right?
I will do Psalm 82 tomorrow cuz in about
an hour and a half I go live again.
Answering common objections by Muslims.
I'll get you the link.
Bless that brother's channel. But let me
show you Leonard Nimoy.
Come on, man. Shoot, man. Where you at,
Leonard? Leonard, why you hiding, bro?
Okay, let me see. Maybe he's over here.
I'll find him. Leonard Nimoy, Mr.
Leaving on a jet plane.
I don't know if I'll be back again. Oh,
baby.
Can you let me find Leonard Nimoy?
Leonard Nimoy, he's the man. He was part
of Star Trek's plan. There you go. Watch
here.
How many of you are shocked to find out
that this is a
rabbinic blessing
because it rabbinical resembles the
sheen
>> [clears throat]
>> the Hebrew alphabet sheen. So, when
Leonard Nimoy would do this, he was
pronouncing a blessing on you. A
rabbinic blessing.
Did you guys know that?
There you go.
Live long and
prosper.
Worshipping, you know, Mother Earth and
the female spirit and the goddess and
the Kabbalah and the New Age. That's
where all this stuff is coming from.
This is the shape of the letter shin.
Hebrew alphabet shin.
Very interesting letter in the in the
language. It It's the first letter in
the word Shaddai.
The first letter in the word shalom.
First letter in the word Shekhinah.
Which is the name of the feminine aspect
of God. Feminine aspect of God.
Live long and prosper.
Image of Surak.
Father of all we now hold true.
That's right.
That's right. People don't realize
they're blessing each other with this.
>> [laughter]
>> That's right.
>> A Jewish actor
made made it part of his alien character
to do the shin sign. Shekhinah, the
female aspect of God.
You see here what the rabbi said about
God.
You know, that he's a he can be a woman
or a man. Doesn't matter.
Right? Shaddai.
>> [snorts]
[laughter]
>> People don't know where you CAN GET
BLESSED.
>> [laughter]
>> AND YOU'RE TELLING ME
they haven't infiltrated?
Yeah, the Shekhinah or Shekinah.
Cuz Shekhinah from Mishkan, Shakan,
meaning to dwell tabernacle, is feminine
noun.
Shekinah is a feminine noun.
Because it's a feminine noun, you'll
speak of it as a woman.
But it doesn't mean it's a woman. So,
the rabbis, being geniuses and into
mysticism, Gnosticism, and new age
demonism,
they took the word Shekinah to refer to
the feminine aspect of God, that female
part of God, cuz God is male and female.
That's rabbinic Judaism.
Right?
That's what they believe about God.
That's why in Kabbalah, you have what's
called the Ain Sof, the infinite, and
the Ain Sof has 10 manifestations called
the Sefirot, Sefirot.
10 of them, they're male and female, and
they can cohabit with each other. That's
how sick, demonic, perverted
Kabbalah is.
Rabbinic Jewish Jewish mysticism.